There's four steps. Eliminate
distractions. Get started. Get better.
Never stop. Number one, elimination of
the things [music] that are distracting
you. When I was young, my father gave me
this advice. Rich people buy time. Poor
people buy stuff. Ambitious people buy
skills. Lazy people buy distraction. I
can give you the first and easiest 2025
prediction. Look at what you spend money
on. Look at your calendar. And wherever
you invest is what you will get more of.
So many people are surprised when they
look at their bank account next year and
it's lower than they want it to be. They
look at their accomplishments from that
year and it's not the things they set
out to do. But when you look at their
calendar and their credit card expenses,
it's very obvious why those things
didn't happen. Because we vote with our
dollars about the things that we care
about. We vote about the type of person
that we want to become. And as the first
thing that you can do today for next
year is actually comment below this
video. And I rarely ask for this. The
thing that you're actually going to do
today, not what you're going to begin
doing next year or what your resolution
is going to be. But if it's important
enough to do for future you, it's
certainly important enough to do for
current you. Because current you, by the
way, is the only you that's ever going
to enjoy life. I'll give you this story.
So I remember when I was a few years
back, I was walking with Ila and we went
to Sephora, which is like a makeup
store. So, we walked inside. You know,
I'm sitting, you know, standing there
awkwardly cuz I'm like, I don't know
what I'm supposed to do here. There's
this lady with the smock who like helps
out and she had these two girls who were
young. They must have been maybe well
about this this old. I'm guessing
between 9 and 40, who knows? She's
leaning over and she has these two paint
brushes in her hands and she says,
"Okay, girls, now that you guys are
women, you need to start budgeting for
this stuff because you're going to be
spending money on this every single
month to do your makeup." And so, the
girls grabbed them. They were super
excited and they went to go check out.
And I saw that exchange as actually a
really beautiful lesson when it comes to
identity. Our priorities we dictate by
what we spend, not by what we say. These
girls, because they wanted to step into
this new identity, had to match it with
new priorities. So they had money or
they had saved up their shekels or
whatever they do for chores or
babysitting or whatever. By doing that,
they had to start prioritizing some of
that money towards their new identity
from girls to women. But the thing is is
that many people who want to start next
year think, okay, well, I'm just going
to see if this happens. But it doesn't
work that way. You have to basically
make the decision that this is the type
of person that I want to become. And
then these are the actions that that
type of person would take. And then we
align our calendars and our budgets in
accordance with that so that the
investments we make yield the results
that we want. But the thing is is that
people want to say, "Hey, wouldn't it be
great if I owned Apple?" But they never
buy the stock. If you want to be that
version of you, you need to start buying
stock in that today. Both by paying in
time and paying in money to vote with
your dollars about what you truly care
about. And the reason that I'm hitting
this so hard is that it's never been
easier than it is today to be
successful. It's also never been easier
to be distracted. So along the theme of
investing in the things that matter
most, the first thing we do is we
eliminate all the stuff that sucks. I
define commitment as the elimination of
alternatives. If you get married, you
eliminate all people of whatever sex
you're married to that are not that
person. Actually, you eliminate everyone
who's not that person independent of
sex, right? That is a commitment, right?
If you enter into a uh partnership and
you say, "I'm not going to do any
business besides this business as part
of the terms," then you've eliminated
all alternatives. And so, if you want
someone to commit, ask them to eliminate
everything else that's not the main
thing. These are all the things, a
laundry list of things that are probably
not your main thing that very likely are
getting in the way. And these are the
most common things that I see in my DMs,
that I see in my comments from people
who are not getting where they want to
go as fast as they'd like to get there.
First big category is bad friends. So if
you want better friends, get used to
seeing them less. Better friends are
busy friends. So I remember when I
started working more and some of the
friends that I had were a little bit
more ambitious, I started realizing that
the people that I liked the most, I
actually didn't spend as much time with.
and the people that were always
available were the ones that I didn't
want to become more like. Here's five
questions you should consider when
thinking about whether to keep a friend
in your life or cut them. Question
number one is, if someone told you that
you're a lot like your friend, would you
take that as a compliment? Second, are
you truly fulfilled by the friendship or
is it just someone to keep you from
being lonely? Third, are you able to be
unapologetically yourself or do you feel
the need to act differently to please
that friend or to be around that friend?
Fourth, do you like who this friend is
right now today or do you like the idea
of the friend and who they could be
someday? And then finally, five, would
you want your future or imagined child
to be friends with someone like this
person? And I think it's a really
wonderful litmus test because it forces
you to take a look outside of yourself
in order to have perspective from a
third-party angle on the true quality of
that person. But the reality is that
rare people are by definition rare. It's
normal to have fewer of them. And so if
you only have a few friends or one good
friend, then that's normal if you want
rare and exceptional friends. If you
have many friends, it's far more likely
that the bar for your friendship is too
low. And to give you a filter that I
actually used for the most important
friend in my life, Ila, I like to think,
does this person have the same scale of
goals that I have? So, it doesn't mean
that they have to have the same goals as
you, but it has to be the same level of
goals as you because at least you're
going in the same direction. So, that's
number one. Number two is, do they have
the same level of dedication and
commitment to those goals? Because I
don't know about you, but I had plenty
of friends who were like, I want to be
an NFL player. I want to be a really
rich tech entrepreneur. I want to be a a
touring musician, right? And they had
these goals, but I'm like, dude, I see
you just playing Fortnite 4 hours a day
and you you practice guitar once a week.
Like, what do you really want that or do
you just like saying it because it makes
you feel good? And so, I wanted people
who walked the walk and I wanted people
who would keep up with my pace. And if
you are someone who's ambitious, and
this is me just talking specifically to
you because there's only a few people
who are watching this who really are.
And you'll know that if it's you, you
have to get used to being alone because
there are seasons where you'll basically
transition from one group of friends
into another. And it's not even a group
of you'll usually transition from a
group of friends into no friends. And
then you'll find one or two people who
are at a new level. And then sometimes
those people introduce you to some of
their friends. And if you keep walking
and you keep outpacing, then that group
will then start retiring past you. and
then maybe one person stays with you,
maybe no one does, and you'll have
another lonely period. I'm saying this
because I used to think that there was
something wrong with me when in reality
I just didn't understand what the nature
of being exceptional meant. And so I'm
saying this purely from a definitional
perspective. To be exceptional means
that you are the exception. It means
that you are not normal. And so it's
normal for normal people to find you
abnormal if you do things that are not
normal. Don't let people who have
mediocre goals deter you from taking
actions that make you great because it
makes you different. Realizing that I
thought most people actually made no
sense. They say they had these goals but
they took no action. And they called me
work obsessed and they would tell me I
should take time off and they're like,
"Hey, you're not you're not you're not
as cool anymore. You're not you're not
hanging out with the boys. like why
aren't you participating in the fantasy
league? Why aren't you watching football
on Sunday with us? And for me, I
actually used to love watching football
uh with my friends. It was actually one
of my biggest things that I look forward
to. But the thing is is that like I
needed that Sunday cuz I had to prep
workouts. I had to prep the music list
for the next day. I had to run billing.
I had to do all this other work. And the
thing is is that like I looked at that
football game and I was like my goals
are more important to me than this. And
so I think that a lot of people don't
actually look at themselves in the
mirror and say like one year from today
will I will I remember this football
game or will I remember the fact that
I'm not where I said I wanted to be and
to me that was significantly more
painful. Now this is an uncomfortable
fact for a lot of people. Your ability
to delay gratification is actually a
function of intelligence. And so your
ability to learn at a longer and longer
delay is something that comes I mean
we're talking from primates all the way
up. And so basically if you want to
teach a monkey how to do something you
have to say hey do this thing and then
immediately give them a reward. And the
longer that period goes on the less
trainable they are. The sign of
intelligence is that you can actually
expand the reinforcement window and they
can still abstract it back to the
original action. If you want to practice
intelligence, then being able to
actively delay your need for a result or
reward from the work you do will make
you a more intelligent person because
your rate of learning will actually
increase despite the fact that your
reward rate will decrease in the short
term. And so to give you full
transparency on what 2025 might look
like if you accomplish your goals at the
end, you might have a different friend
group or no friends at all for a season
because you don't become like the people
you admire. You become like the people
you want to impress. Harvard made this,
you know, wonderful study years ago
about the best predictor of someone's
long-term material success was what they
called their reference group. Now, this
has been misqued in places by the five
people you spend the most time with, but
it's actually the five people you
compare yourself to, and that's a very
big difference. Now, I want to take it a
step further because I think to myself,
what are the things that affect our
behavior? And so, it's really about the
people that you want to impress, not
necessarily even who you compare
yourself to, because it's the people
whose voices you hear when you're about
to make a big life decision. And so when
you make a big life decision, you don't
listen to the people closest to you. You
should listen to the people closest to
your goals. And some of them may not be
in your neighborhood or your city or
your state or your high school or your
college. They might just be people you
follow on the internet. And you have to
abstract what would that person think
about this decision? Not my mom, not my
homie, not my uncle, or that person at
church. And so I think this is a great
transition of thinking through instead
of necessarily even having mentors,
having heroes and transposing what you
think their decision-making calculus
would be onto your life. And so it's
interesting is that I will have
conversations with entrepreneurs and
they'll say, "Hey, here's my current
condition. This is my desired state.
This is what I perceive my obstacle to
be." And I say, "Okay, well what do you
think?" And they're like, "Well, I think
you're going to say I should do X, Y,
and Z." And I'm like, "You're right. Why
aren't you?" They're like, "Well," and
the thing is is that basically what they
answer with after that well is in
essence other people's opinion who
aren't at the place they want to be.
Here's the the uncomfortable truth,
which is that winners focus on winning.
Losers focus on winners. And you never
receive hate from above, always below,
because winners have their eyes on the
goal, not on other people. And so, you
have to decide whether you want to be a
loser or a winner. And I'm just being
real with you. what this looks like in
reality and maybe for you in 2025 will
be like this. First, you look like an
idiot to everyone else while you try to
figure it out. Then everyone else looks
like an idiot for ever doubting you.
Seasons. And so, everyone takes a
different amount of years to stop giving
a about what everyone else thinks.
And if you're going to get there
eventually, you might as well start
today and enjoy the benefits longer. So,
if I'm 85 years old, I think about what
that man cares about. And that man cares
about very, very little. All you have to
do is talk to an elderly person or a
grandparent and be like, "What do you
think about this?" A lot of like, "Ah,
who cares?" Like, it doesn't matter.
Life is literally too short. They
literally don't have time for it. And so
I think to myself, if that's the
ultimate version of me, if I'm going to
get there eventually, and that's what
the wisest people think after having the
most life experience, then why would I
not try to cheat code that into today?
And then not have to go looking back
from 85 and think, man, I wish I knew
then what I know now, look forward to
85year-old self and say, I am going to
choose to learn the lesson I know I'm
going to learn and act as if I knew it
today. Because the difference between
them and you is that what they consider
work, you consider life. And so you have
to accept that you have a fundamental
different understanding of how life
works. And I believe that is a more
accurate view of reality. The reason
that the rich can get richer is because
they see the world differently than the
poor. And so it makes sense that if your
poor friends don't see what you see,
that they see through the lens of
poverty. And all my goal in life is to
be able to see reality more accurately.
And so in the beginning, you have to
develop this armor, this thick skin
around people saying those little snide
comments of like, you work too hard,
you're too obsessed, you have a toxic
work capacity, and why are you working
weekends, why are you working late
nights, you're you're not like this is
not worth it, they're not paying you
enough for the work that you do. All of
these different things. Because
eventually that armor on the outside
actually just becomes one with you. And
you don't even hear it anymore. Because
I can promise you that those people who
were in my life decades ago, they're
just not even I don't hear those those
claims anymore for two reasons. One,
because my reality changed so
drastically that they couldn't say
anything. And secondarily, they're just
not in my world anymore. I was only able
to get here because what they deemed
acceptable, I deemed intolerable. How
far you go in life, I truly believe this
is based and predicated only on one
thing which is your actual standard. And
so I believe that the person who runs
any company or runs any division should
be the person who has the highest
standards. And if there's ever a day
that someone has a higher standard for
acquisition.com than me, they should run
this instead of me because they would be
the one who's best serving the company.
And so the person who should have the
highest standard for you is you. And so
it makes sense that they have a lower
bar, but why would I listen to their bar
on my life? I think that that standard
is the one thing that rich kids get from
rich parents more than anything else is
because they have an expectation of
life. They don't accept opportunities
that are below that standard. And so
they actually get their huge leg up on
the pick on the vehicles that they
choose to pursue. And so one of the
tougher parts if you're not from an area
where people make a lot of money or not
from you don't know anybody who's a you
know super successful entrepreneur is
that you basically have to borrow
someone else's measuring stick and you
have to say is this the standard that
Elon would pursue. Is this the standard
Bezos would pursue? Is this the standard
Jobs would pursue? And if it isn't then
why are you doing it? If you want to be
like them then act like them. If you
want to be like your friends, then you
can act like your friends, but don't be
surprised that you have what they have
or lack what they lack. If we're
thinking about elimination, we're
eliminating bad friends and tangentially
their opinions about you that are
affecting your behavior. So the next
thing are what things are playing
interference on your time and your
attention. All right, so I would say
opinions of other people are affecting
your behavior and your decisions. I
think that your environment affects your
efficiency of behavior. So think about
how much more you get per hour of
output. If you can't sit still, ignore
notifications, and focus on one task for
eight hours straight. Never expect to
build anything great. And as
uncomfortable as that is, it's also the
truth. Like I I don't know a single
incredibly successful entrepreneur that
can't sit down and have hyperfocused
periods of time, sometimes weekends,
weeks at a time where they don't talk to
anyone and they just hammer away. And
it's whether they're coding for software
or they're making some insane marketing
campaign and all the email follow-ups
and all the text follow-ups and and the
affiliate uh you know promotions and
incentives or someone who's creating a
product that they're designing and
they're in the shop and they keep
tweaking at it. Or there's somebody
who's who's hypers scaling a company and
saying I'm going to sit in 20 interviews
a day for for seven days straight so I
can hire 20 people this week because I
need to get going. Right? Like if you
can't sit still and ignore notifications
and focus for a day, nothing great will
get accomplished because it's not about
what you want, it's about what's
required. And it's and whether that's
your best or not is irrelevant. It's
just there's a price tag and you got to
be willing to pay for it or you don't
get the thing. And a lot of times it's
not what you want. And I I I I spend a
lot of time trying to dispel the concept
of like follow your passion because I
think it leads more people astray than
it helps because it's very easy for
someone who's successful who's already
delegated tons of things to only then
focus on their area of genius and then
say here for my seat do what I do. But
there's a very big difference between
doing what someone does and doing what
they did to get there. And I think this
is what's lost in a lot of the content
that I see in the entrepreneurial space.
And to be clear, whenever I'm trying to
get to the next level, I often have to
take on things that I don't know how to
do and I have to learn how to do them,
which means I have to suck for a period
of time. And sucking sucks. But the
thing is is you have to be able to
embrace that period of time and say like
this is the cost of greatness. And so
I'll give you something very tactical.
So I have timers in a lot of my offices
and my team has adopted this too, which
is I like to time block, which is
essentially saying how long do I think
this is going to take? And you can do
this on a week scale, you can do it on a
daily level. It depends on the level of
project you're tackling. But for me,
even on the most micro level, I say,
"Okay, how long should this take?" I'll
then crank this thing. Boop. I think
this should take 20 minutes. And then I
hit start and I let the timer go. And if
for whatever reason something distracts
me, I pause it so that I know that I
didn't actually work that period of
time. And so what happens is it will
give you a very real look at how long
you're actually working versus how long
you think you're working. and you tell
other people working and you Instagram
how long you're working. And as I've
become more efficient at work, meaning
my output per unit of time has gone up,
I've realized that there's just been a
significant decrease in the distractions
that I allow to interrupt me. Again, if
you want to stay focused, staying
focused is not like zeroing in and
saying, "I'm going to do it just like
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
just zoom in on this thing." It's more
that focus occurs when you remove
everything else. what's left is focus.
And so Jerry Seinfeld has this uh this
famous process that he talks about with
writing and I think writers are also
wonderful people for talking to for deep
work because it's the nature of the work
they do. One of the things that he did
and he has done for years for his
standup so he can script it out is that
he locks himself in a room that has no
windows and has nothing but a yellow
notepad and a pen. And he tells himself
that he has to go in that room and he
doesn't have to write but he can't do
anything else. And so what ends up
happening is that writing occurs as a
default. And so focus kind of works the
same way. You eliminate everything else
by to create focus. You don't try and
push harder while also having these
disruptions. So there's three easy ways
that I make my phone less distracting.
The first is I switch it to grayscale.
And so grayscale decreases consumption
across all people by 30%ish. And that's
research back. It's pretty cool. The
second thing is turning off all
notifications across all apps on your
phone because you never want your app to
be dictating when it's convenient for
the app to disrupt you. Like, how
ridiculous is that? But we let apps have
that permission. Most phones and people
want to push notifications to you. I
want to pull them when it's convenient
for me. The third thing is other people.
And so I have a mode on my phone where
no one can get through. And when I do
that, then I can reach out to them when
it's convenient for me. Because if it's
actually an emergency, call 911. And if
it's not a true emergency, then it can
wait. And my team wanted to remind me
that I don't email. I heard in uh I
think it was like 2016 that Bill Clinton
didn't use email. And I was like, if
he's the president, he doesn't use
email, I cannot use email. And so uh my
team doesn't contact me via email. And
so if you can eliminate entire channels,
that's also an easier way to concentrate
uh fewer flows of communication. And
here's the thing, it's always harder,
takes longer, and costs more than you
think it will. That is a reflection of
poor expectations, not that that reality
is bad. And so it makes sense that it
would be harder, take longer, and cost
more. Because if it didn't, then
everyone would have it, and everyone had
it, then it wouldn't be worthwhile. And
so literally the difficulty of the task
that you embark on is proportional to
the reward that you ultimately get
because you are the asset that you build
more than the achievement. And so if
it's hard, that's amazing because it
will make you that much harder once you
conquer it. And it will also make it
harder for anybody else who wants to
follow in your footsteps. And so the
higher up the mountain you climb, the
thinner the air gets and the rarer the
climber or explorer must be in order to
get there. And so, I don't know about
you, but I would so much rather climb a
mountain that so few people have been
able to climb so that I can see a view
that other people haven't seen. And so,
speaking of expectations, let me talk
about the worst expectation of all,
which is entitlement, which is the
expectation of life or other people to
give you something without earning it.
And I think that this is is a is a virus
in today's culture right now. And so,
there's the famous quote, "Hard times
create strong men. Strong men create
good times. Good times create weak men
and weak men create hard times. It makes
sense that right now we have a lot of
weak men because it's been pretty good
times. The good news about that is that
it's so easy to beat them. You just have
to show up, be on time, prepare the
night before, remembers people's names,
actually follow up when you say you were
going to, and try like you mean it
rather than trying like you want to get
credit for trying. And I see this is
this this thing that's that that's
pervasive right now is that people will
comment or they'll DM me and they're
like, "Hey, I'm trying really hard." As
though I'm supposed to give them credit
for trying. The world doesn't work that
way. It gives you credit for achieving.
And the reason that you want credit for
trying is because you want it to cost
less, take shorter time period, and be
easier. And so if you restate your
complaint about the difficulty as, "Oh,
I have false expectations about the ease
or the price tag of this goal," then all
of a sudden you realize that the only
real problem was that you expected it to
cost less. It's like going to the store
and being like, "Oh, I've got these
Jordans that I really want to buy. I got
$50. I'm so excited to buy them." You go
to the store, it's and see that they're
$300. At that point, you can just say,
"Jeans aren't for me." Or you can say,
"Oh, I will have to keep working and
keep saving so that I can afford this."
And so it's a lot about affording the
goals that you want to achieve. And a
lot of things that we have to spend in
order to get them is the time and the
rejection of not achieving what we want
on the timeline we originally thought.
Like what makes success hard is that the
expectation that society puts because we
only see the highlight reel. You
actually only see people after they
finish the race. People think success is
like watching a marathon, not running a
marathon. When you watch a marathon, you
look at the beginning and you look at
the end. It only takes you a couple of
seconds to see both of those. But
running a marathon is four, five, six
straight hours of breathing heavy,
wondering when it's going to end,
counting, starting to play games in your
mind of like, okay, I'm I'm twothirds of
the way there. I'm two two more quarters
of that. I'm only one of the of 1/8 of
the way there. And you keep doing this
to play tricks on your mind to keep
going. But the thing is is that in a
mile marker race, it's very clear to
know how you're going to get to the
finish line and how long it's going to
take. The only difference with success
is that you just have to keep running
and you don't know where the finish line
is. And people will only cheer you on at
that finish line that they don't know
where it is either. Which means you have
to get used to running alone. And so the
difficulty is you have to start running
and you have to keep running, but you
just don't know whether you're running
for a mile or 300. And so this is where
the pacing is important. So a lot of
people will run really hard. They'll
they'll think because they only saw the
beginning of the marathon on TV and the
finish of the marathon on TV that they
can just sprint because both of those
clips only lasted a couple of seconds.
So, they start their marathon of success
of whatever it is they're going after by
sprinting as hard as they can and then
they realize that there's no one around
and there's just a bunch of open road
ahead of them and they're like, "How
long is this going to take?" And that's
when reality sets in. And so, I make
these videos to say that a lot of times
it's going to take longer. So, one of
the big nasty things that you have to
eliminate on this path is the identity
that you have about yourself, the isms
that you claim. And so, for example,
like, oh, I'm a I'm a neat freak. I'm a
I'm not good at math. I'm not techy. And
so, you make these statements and they
don't serve you. Fundamentally, you
should have one razor that rules all
decisions. And I this is this is pretty
cruel, but it's also the reality of the
world, which is does this thing person
belief make it more or less likely that
I hit my goals? And so if you run every
single thing you do, the actions you
take, the people you hang out with, you
having your phone in the room, you
saying I'm not techy, does this increase
or decrease the likelihood that you hit
your goals? And I'm not saying this to
preach because I had one that I dealt
with for a long time. So I always
considered myself to be bad at math. I
remember I was decent at math and then
in ninth grade I had a really bad
teacher and it basically put me back a
year. Basically after algebra I didn't
really learn anything because the year
after that I didn't have the the
foundations from the year before. The
difficulty was I kept saying after that
point I'm just not good at math. But
when I was in my 20s I made the decision
that that didn't serve me anymore. And
so I was like okay well what would I
have to do to feel like I was good at
math? And I was like, well, people who
like can do math in their head. I think
that's a pretty cool thing. And so I
didn't use a calculator for anything for
years. And then I learned, I mean, I
made a lot of mistakes in the beginning,
but then I got better and better at
doing math in my head. And I would check
it obviously after I was done, but I
always let my head try and do it first.
And so nowadays, if you were to ask
people, man, is Alex good at math?
They're like, dude, he just rattles off
numbers like crazy. But the thing is is
that until I was in my 20s, I thought I
was bad at math. And so it's like we are
so much more pliable than we think we
are. And we had something that set us on
a trajectory a little bit earlier in
life that just gave us maybe a little
bit of disadvantage. Fine, because you
just have to get over it. Everyone's
childhood was difficult. And if you want
to win the award for hardest childhood,
congrats, you win. You feel better,
right? No one cares about what happened
to you then. Only what you can make
happen now. Identity is a lie. We only
describe people about who they are by
what they do. Doing is being. And so if
you want to be somehow different, you
have to do different things. And then
only afterwards will people describe you
based on the actions you take. Think
about back in the day, the actual names
people had was he's John the Carpenter,
he's John the Stonesmith, he's John the
Mason, right? People literally had their
names based on what they did. That
hasn't changed. The first thing you do
when you meet somebody is you find out
what do what do you do? And that that
gives you indications. And if you want
to describe who someone is, what do you
say? You describe what they do. And so
this means that our identity is 100%
under our control because we control
what we do. And then only after the fact
will other people describe you in that
way. So we covered environmental things
like with the phone and having a timer.
We covered interpersonal things in terms
of our identity and voting with the our
dollars and time about the things that
we care about. We eliminated the bad
people and their opinions about us that
affect our behavior. And so we've
eliminated all these things. So now
we've made room to get started. And the
good news is you only need three things
to win. The balls to start, the brains
to learn, and the heart to never give
up. And the best thing is you already
have all three. And for the girls, you
have gonads. So it's fine. it still
counts. And so my ask of you is to make
the commitment. Now, this is again the
elimination of alternatives, to make the
commitment to never stop. And so it
doesn't mean that I'm asking you to
commit to be successful. I'm asking you
to commit to keep running, to keep
walking the marathon. Even if you have
to pant and you have to slow down, you
just can't stop. And so the best way to
hit next year's goals is to not wait
until next year to work on them. Is to
start now. Because I'll tell you this,
if you feel like you need a special
occasion to begin making your life
better, then it assumes that a special
occasion must always be there for you to
want to improve yourself. It shows that
you don't think today is worth
improving. And so that means that you
typically will always cast forward when
you think things are worth improving.
And so the easiest way to vote with your
action is to make today the only day
that is good because it's the only day
you have control over. My hot take,
which shouldn't be, is you don't have to
wait until January 1 to better yourself.
And I'm purposely posting this before
the year ends because I think it's
stupid to wait. Like, why would you wait
on getting better? Why would you? Like,
if you had a lottery ticket, why would
you wait to cash it in? You would cash
it in as fast as humanly possible. And
that lottery ticket is the life that you
want on the other side of this. Why
would you wait? Here's a harsh truth.
You're young. You've got time. False.
All that lie does is extend how long it
takes people to realize tomorrow isn't
guaranteed. Nothing is going to be easy.
Get over it. It takes time to get good.
And the sooner you start, the sooner you
act. And the sooner you act, the sooner
you get. And don't stop until you do.
And as harsh as that sounds, I do have
good news. It only takes 20 hours of
focused effort to get decent at
anything. The problem is people wait
years before they start their first
hour. So many of you could probably
start achieving next year goals before
the end of this year. 20 hours is not
that long. If you're like, man, I really
want to learn ads. I really want to
learn how to make content. I really want
to learn how to edit videos. I really
want to learn how to sell. You can do
that now. And you can have that skill.
Like we can onboard a new sales guy in
in in a few days. there's this massive
delay that people think because of the
unknown. They don't know what is going
to happen and so they therefore assume
that it's bad. And so the reality is
that most people don't like surprises
even if they're good ones. Have you ever
people like, "Oh, I don't like surprise
parties." It's a party. Why
would you hate a surprise party that's
in your favor? You hate it because you
don't like the unknown. And so it's a
really good thing to test for yourself,
which is why would I hate a good
surprise?
You hate it because there's a
possibility that the surprise is
negative. But on a long time horizon,
you know, 85year-old you isn't even
going to remember it to begin with. This
is a this is going to be a weird one for
you, but just stay with me. If you've
ever been so drunk that you're throwing
up and you think to yourself, "Man, I'm
probably not going to remember this."
The good news is is that once you do
succeed, that terrible period of
vomiting or whatever the difficulty is
that you're going through, it'll
actually compress in your mind. And so,
as difficult as it may seem in the
moment, it actually doesn't stay with
you. All you'll have left is the thing
you accomplished, you won't remember the
work that it took to get there. There'll
be a significant discount on the
punishment you endured. I tend to have a
bad habit of really not looking back
very much. And so I occasionally will go
through my photos and I am reminded
about all of the mistakes and the
detours that I took along the way to
where I wanted to go. And I'll tell you
the story that my father told me when I
was uh very impatient. He said, "Listen,
you think that this is taking too long
for you to be successful?" He said, "Do
you know how long it took me to become a
doctor?" And I was like, "No." He's
like, "Well, so my father's a run-in and
he left the country to get educated and
there was a program for anybody who was
a runin that the government would pay
for your schooling as long as you came
back with the education." Now, the
revolution occurred during the time he
was away. So, he actually never got to
go back. He went to uh France, Paris, to
try and enter medical school. Only
problem, he didn't speak French. And so
he's trying to do premed in another
language as somebody who doesn't even
share the same alphabet. And so he
failed that year. He then took a the
second year he tried again because
you're allowed in in in France. It's a
different system. You can just basically
try as many times as you want. He
started again and the second year he
failed again and then he talked to his
brother and he's like, I don't know if
being a doctor's for me. Like I just
feel like imagine this like failing two
full years in a row. and his brother
said, "Hey, why don't you go to Belgium?
You know, change the environment, you
know, different different school,
different people. Go there." So, he went
to Belgium and then his third try, he
made it past his first year. Now, mind
you, at this point, he had two years of
learning French and so he was able to
finally actually understand what the
professor was saying. So, was it that he
wasn't smart enough to understand how to
become a doctor or was it that he just
had other skills that he lacked along
the way? And so a lot of people right
now are judging the fact that they
didn't succeed because they somehow
think it's some innate trait. I'm not
smart enough. I'm not good enough. But
sometimes you just lack some
prerequisite skills, right? Like if
you're like trying to learn calculus and
you've never done arithmetic before,
it's going to be really hard, right?
Dare I say impossible. And so if you
jump straight into calculus, you're not
going to win. So sometimes you have to
take two steps back in order to build
the foundation to get forward. Now, I'm
going to keep the story going. So he
then graduates in uh you know seven
years because how long it takes the
actual medical school system is
different in in in in uh in Europe. They
actually do college and the the next
degree all is one thing. So seven years
later he graduates. Okay. Then he's this
Iranian dude can't go back to his own
country. Meets a girl in Belgium. She
says I'm from the US. And so he comes
back to the US with the lady who would
eventually become my mother. And when
he's in the US, he then his doctor, his
his MD doesn't apply here. So he then
has to basically do it again in the
United States. And in order to do this,
you have to get a residency. Now,
getting a residency as someone who's a
foreigner back then was pretty tough.
And so it took him two years where he
had to basically work minimum wage jobs.
He was like uh he had to like run slides
like radiology slides back and forth as
like a runner, a courier. when he was a
full surgeon, but he couldn't do it here
in the US. And so imagine how
emasculinating it is, right? Where your
wife comes back, she's able, she was a
US citizen and had all this other stuff,
right? And she could, she got her
internship immediately because uh she
was US and she was a girl, whatever. And
my father didn't. And so he then had to
do two more years where he didn't have
progress. So he he told me this whole
story and then eventually obviously he
got the he got the residency and then he
was able to get in the path. But if you
look at that, he basically had four or
five years of his life where there was
basically no net gain in progress
towards his goals. And so he's telling
me this story when he's 50 and he's
like, "Look at my life now." He's like,
"No one knows." He's like, "No one asks
me how long it took. They just know what
I have now and what I can do now." And
so you have this idea that it's that it
should take a certain period of time. It
it should only last this long. It should
be this level of difficulty. But the
thing is is just that that level of
perseverance when he decided to go out
on his own and start his own practice
rather than and and left the practice
that he was working in, he then didn't
know anyone and he still had a heavy
accent, was a new guy in a new area and
it took him time to build up. And what
did he do? My dad learned how to be a
general contractor. He built his own
surgical center because he couldn't
afford having these outsourced third
parties that charge $250,000 to build a
surgery center. He built his his for a
fraction of that. And so as my dad going
to Home Depot, measuring and figuring
these things out as a full plastic
surgeon, it's not about the resources
you have. It's about how resourceful
you're willing to be right now. Getting
started is 100% under your control. And
I love taking this frame, which is that
every self-made billionaire is
self-made. Now, if you're like, wait,
there are billionaires who aren't
self-made, right? That's why I didn't
say all billionaires. Every self-made
billionaire is self-made. And every
self-made millionaire is self-made. And
here's the one people hate. Every
self-made person in poverty is
self-made. Now, that may make you feel
uncomfortable. And you know what? You
may be right. You probably did have more
disadvantages. You probably did have
things that worked against you. And now
what? You're right. So that's it then
for you. The rest of your life will
never go the way you want it to go. The
harsh truth here is if you want to feel
better, blame others. If you want to get
better, blame yourself. And so my father
told me that story multiple times in my
life, as I'm sure your fathers have told
you stories multiple times in your life,
or you had a parent or an uncle or a
brother, and they told you those big
meaningful stories. And so I'll tell you
another time he told me it. So after I
lost everything for the second time,
think about like I tell the story, but
it's very easy to gloss over, but think
about this. I had left my job, went to a
new area, didn't know anyone, started a
gym, didn't have enough money to have an
apartment, slept at my gym, just
grassroots, got it going, made the gym
successful by working there every hour
of the day. Was finally successful
enough to be able to open a second
location, a third, a fourth, a fifth, a
sixth. finally feel like I I tasted
success, like I'm actually doing
something. I'm actually pretty good
here. Like that bet that I made actually
paid off and then I lose it all. And so
I I I sell all those locations. I put
the money in a new thing and then it's
gone. And so I could look back and say,
"Wow, I just spent all those years and I
actually have nothing to show for it.
The only thing I would have had to show
was the money that I made." But my
father retold me that story and he said
it was never about the amount of
failures failures he had. It was about
the education that he had. And so one of
the other repeated fatherisms that he
gave me was that education is the only
thing that no one can take from you. The
skills you have, the skills you acquire
along the way are the only thing that
are truly yours. There's nothing else in
this world that actually belongs to you.
Your your clothes can get stolen. the
belongings you have. And he said this
from a place of reality, which is my
family came from a country that took all
of our assets. They seized everything.
They seized land. They seized homes.
They seized wealth. They just said, "Oh
yeah, all that that's ours now. Good
luck." This may not be as real for
people in the United States. But having
people who everyone in my family had
everything taken from them that is very
evident in how they talked to me and how
I've always seen the world as these
things are ephemeral. These material
goods, the studio, the setup, the
lights, the whatever, the platforms
like gone. But the thing is is that my
father came here with $1,000 because of
the revolution and had nothing and built
the life he has. And you can lose it all
and gain it back. And so we've seen so
many entrepreneurs who've actually lived
through this cycle. It's actually a
common thing in entrepreneurship and
it's because you have to understand and
respect risk. The beauty of it is that
after you fail, the likelihood that
you're successful goes up, not down.
This is the part that people miss. They
fail and think it somehow decreases the
likelihood of success, but it actually
increases it. And so it's like you want
to just get the failures out of the way.
Why would you not want something that
increases the likelihood you hit your
goal? And the reason that it increases
that likelihood is that failure
is a requisite
probability for taking action. And so
anyone who has failed has taken more
action than someone who's done nothing.
Which means it increases the likelihood
that they are successful. And so when
you fail, you get feedback. And when you
get feedback, you get better. And when
you get better, it increases the
likelihood you win. Losers
stay losers by never being willing to
lose.
Everyone loses before they win. And so
there's this great moment in the Matrix,
which is the the famous jump where Neo
is trying to jump across the buildings
and everyone's gathered around because
they think he's the one. He obviously
takes the jump and he falls and they're
like, "Ah, what does it mean? What does
it mean?" And Cipher, who ended up
eventually being the Judas of this,
says, "Everybody falls the first time."
And so even the one or the person who
was going to become the one was somebody
who had to fail first. And I love that
because everyone falls the first time.
Your first business is very unlikely to
be your last business. The first product
you have will be a product that you'll
be embarrassed of years from now. But
what's important is having the product,
getting the product, building the
product, launching the product, shooting
the shot. And so if you're never willing
to lose, you're never going to win. So,
in 2025, if you start a podcast or you
start making content or you start doing
cold outbound or you you you you take a
new job, whatever it is, just remember
that your second try after you fail,
which you inevitably will, takes twice
the emotional effort, but half the
actual effort. So, you'll fail and
you'll emotionally feel bad. But guess
what you did? You actually gripped your
hands on the unknown. And you go from
unknown optimism to known pessimism. So
it's like okay now I know what it takes
I now have realistic expectations what
is required in order to be successful
and although it may be bigger than I
originally thought I now can quantify
what is required to win and so here's
the thing the best entrepreneurs in the
world have the biggest failure resumes
and so I don't even want you to win I
want you to build your failure resume
and so if you're like a must be easy for
you to say I lost money on my first two
real estate deals I ever did. Almost
lost all the money I put in. I've lost
money on crypto when I put it in years
ago. I lost money on uh bad hires. I've
lost millions in bad hires. Actual hard
costs, not soft costs. I've had six
failed businesses. I've had nine failed
partnerships. And so I bring these
things up because like you're not going
to hit it out of the park on the first
shot. But the crazy thing about how
success works is that you only need to
win once. That's the crazy part is you
only have to win once. I'll read you
this quote from Jeff Bezos, which is
what I started my first book, $100
million offers with. We all know that if
you swing for the fences, you're going
to strike out a lot, but you're also
going to hit some home runs. The
difference between baseball and
business, however, is that baseball has
a truncated outcome distribution. When
you swing, no matter how well you
connect with the ball, the most runs you
can hit is four. In business, every once
in a while, when you step up to the
plate, you can score 1,000 runs. This
longtail distribution of returns is why
it's important to be bold. Big winners
pay for so many experiments. And when he
says big winners pay, they pay in
failures. They pay in the scars that
they have to incur and endure along to
hitting it out of the park and hitting
it out so big that they never have to
swing again. And so I want to make this
as real as I possibly can. I just found
an old note from myself to myself that's
12 years old. And so I talked about my
$10,000 per month income goal. And
reading it got me actually pretty choked
up. This is all to say that no matter
where you're at in your journey, you've
just got to believe with all your
heart that you're going to make
it because no one else is going to
believe for you. Because you can never
expect someone to invest in you more
than you invest in yourself. And the
crazy thing is some people say they'd
kill for a shot or they die for a chance
when in reality they won't even wake up
60 minutes earlier for it. So, we've
eliminated the distractions, all of the
things associated with not doing this
stuff. And now, hopefully, I've removed
some of the mental BS around getting
started. And so, now once you start, you
got to get better. Connections, money,
looks, intelligence, those are all
great, but you can beat someone with all
of those things if they have only one
trait. An insatiable desire to improve.
No matter where they start, it's hard to
beat someone who improves every second
of every day without giving up. And this
is why earlier I said ambitious people
buy skills and they pay for those skills
with time and money. And in order to
have the time and money to invest in
those skills, they have to take them
from somewhere else. Because the thing
is is that your resources are zero sum.
And this is something that a lot of
people aren't comfortable with. Whatever
you choose to spend your time on, you
take from something else. Whatever you
choose to spend your money on, you take
from something else. And so, most people
don't have a resources issue. They have
a priorities problem. You are choosing
to say that other things are more
important. And hey, I want to be real.
If that stuff is more important to you,
then amazing. You want it life.
Congratulations. But if you don't have
what you want and you're spending money
to proliferate a life that is not the
one you want to lead, then you need to
shift the list to invest the time and
money and pull from those things that
you don't want to put more in the ones
you do. And you want to starve out
failure. So think about this. One of the
easiest ways to to have more money is to
work more hours. And you're like, how is
that possible? Well, when you work more
hours, it actually kills two birds. One
is that you actually make more money
when you work more hours, but on top of
that, you don't spend money because you
have less time to spend it. And so every
hour of work is a net positive in two
directions. So it saves you money you're
not spending and makes you money. And so
you want to find those little twists
that you can make in your investments of
time and money that are outsized. It's
not just that you gain, you also stop
the loss. I've always been willing to
bet big on me. And so, a lot of you guys
are trying to like bet big on Dogecoin
or some meme thing or like some
get-richqu. And I promise you, the guys
who have all the money know how to do it
better than you. And if you have your
last thousand or 5,000 or $10,000 that
you're like, "What do I do with it?" Bet
on you because you'll never sell you.
You're a long-term hold, right? And so,
if you get better, you guarantee the
win. And every investment you make
compounds. You guarantee compounding
because every skill stacks on top of
other skills. Steve Jobs talked about
how when he went to college and learned
calligraphy, it was the reason that
fonts showed up in the Mac later. And so
he talks about you can only connect the
dots looking back. You want to double
down on investing more into you getting
skills. And I'll tell you something that
you probably don't know. So I spent
$10,000 and I only had 50 saved up after
years of being a consultant. So I had
$50,000 saved up. Was 23 years old. as
my life savings. I spent $10,000 to get
a gym coach. I joined a mastermind for
gym owners. Fun fact, though, I didn't
have a gym. But I figured if I go to a
mastermind of gym owners, I'm going to
learn so many of the things that they
made mistakes on when they started their
gym. They're they're going to have
opinions on how I should lay out the
square footage, what what locations I
should pick, what model I should use.
And so rather than say, "Oh, I'm just
going to find out all these failures on
my own my own and and take five times as
long," I was like, "I'd rather pay
$10,000 to pull five years forward into
the present." And so I was able to get
that first location up and profitable
and outsource by month nine. Now, some
of the guys in the mastermind were at
year five and still hadn't done that. I
pay down my ignorance tax as much as I
possibly can because the cost of you not
being able to achieve your dreams, the
price is ignorance. And the debt that
you pay is the distance between where
you are and how much you'd be making if
you knew how to do it. I I've told this
story before, but I think it's so it's
it's something that's so ingrained in
how I think in terms of how I price what
I'm willing to pay in time or money. And
before I tell that story, I move
geographically whenever I see an
opportunity to get around someone who's
better than me. And so when I wanted to
learn fitness stuff, I moved to an area
where I knew there was other fitness
entrepreneurs that I was like, well,
maybe I'll be able to hang out with them
a little bit and I'll learn a little bit
there. And I went to a city I didn't
know anything about. I knew no one. And
when I wanted to when I wanted to uh get
in the gym space, I said, well,
California is like the capital of
fitness, SoCal. So, I'm going to move
out to Southern California because the
best guys will be there. and if I can
win there, I'll be able to win anywhere.
And so I moved out to California without
knowing anyone. Whenever I've had these
big transitions in my life is not only
being willing to bet with my money and
bet with my time, but I also bet with my
geographic location. I'm willing to risk
losing the relationships that I had to
gain relationships that I need. And so
2025 for you might mean that you have to
leave where you're at. And that could
mean across town, but it could also mean
across the country or even across into a
different country. It may mean that
you're going to spend take all this
money that you used to spend here and
spend it in an entirely different way.
You probably are going to have less
stuff and that's okay because that stuff
only deteriorates. It only gets worse.
But you will only get better. Don't
invest in Dogecoin. Don't even invest in
the S&P 500. Invest instead in the
SM500. Invest in you because you will
always beat a 10% return in the stock
market. And if you think that Dogecoin
is going to out compete your personal
growth, you're never going to win.
Anyone can get rich fast as long as
you're willing to make no money for a
long period of time while you work to
get good enough to get rich fast. And so
I told you I'll tell you that story. The
story goes like this. A guy is actually
using this as a sales close to an
audience. He wrote a million dollars on
a whiteboard in front of an audience.
And so then he called out to a lady in
the front row and he said, "How much do
you make, ma'am?" and she said, "
$50,000."
And he said, "Okay,
well, right now you pay reality $950,000
every single year for not knowing how to
make a million dollar." And when I saw
that, I realized that the value of the
skill of making a million dollars is the
difference between what I'm making and
what I could be making. And people
wildly undervalue how much more they
could be making once they have a skill.
And so if you're the type of person who
can actually follow instructions, show
up on time, smile, be able to fail, and
keep going, virtually all education will
net you a positive yield. Because let me
ask you a question. Would you pay
$950,000
to make a million dollars and be able to
make a million dollars every year? Well,
that would be an insane deal. You pay it
once and you get the skill forever. So
every year after that you make a million
dollars a year. Well, of course you
should. Now, once you make the million
dollars a year, are you willing to give
a 100% of what you make to make $10
million a year? Of course you should.
And that's why education is by far the
highest return. You can learn how to
make a million dollar a year for
probably close to $200,000 a year. And
you're like, well, where where do I
spend that? You'll spend that on
conferences. You'll spend it on
seminars. and it'll likely be in 2,000
to to 5,000 sometimes $30,000 chunks,
but for some reason you're willing to
spend this on some academic who hasn't
been in reality for 20 years because
they're on tenure and thinks that the
world uh is just going to hand you stuff
because that's their reality because
they're government funded. Or you can
pay money to people who live in real
private businesses who do this stuff for
a living. And here's the thing. I have
never paid for education and not gotten
more than what I paid for. Now, I don't
want to conflate that with the fact that
I've paid for things that I didn't think
was worth that money to other people,
but I always ask myself, okay, number
one, how can I become the best student
who's ever gone through this? How do I
become this person's number one success
story? And I've told every program,
every partner, every vendor that I've
ever worked with, I will be your biggest
success story. And so the reality is
once I am their biggest success story,
is that because of them or because of
me? And I think that's a choice that you
get to make. Am I going to be the number
one success story or do I want to be
right and prove that they're not good?
Well, congratulations. Maybe they're not
that good. Well, what does that leave
you with? No skills and less money. If
you choose to succeed anyways and say,
"What can I learn from this person?"
Because I've learned just as much from
bad people as I have from good. Because
a lot of times getting good is actually
the removal of bad. And so if you find
out other ways that people do a terrible
job, it's also a wonderful way of
figuring out how to not do a terrible
job. And so if I want to create a
product that's exceptional and I say,
let's say I want to put a phone, a
camera, the internet, email, all in one
place. If you remove all of the stuff
that sucks from all of those things,
what you're left with is an iPhone. Most
times you can always get more than what
you pay for when you invest in you. So
let's get really tactical. If you really
want to double down on you, which will
by far I mean think about this 10%
improvement is the S&P 500. So you're
saying that you could take Okay, let's
be real. Let's do let's do real math. So
let's say that you've got $10,000 saved
up. Okay, let's say that's what your
savings is, which by the way makes you
like a top 40% American, FYI. So, let's
say you've got $10,000 saved up. You
could put in the S&P 500 and have that
$10,000 be 10,900
one year later. Or you can spend that on
something that can triple your earning
capacity and next year instead of
making, let's say, $50,000 a year, you
make $100,000 a year. Well, which of
these increases, the $50,000 plus
increase is more than the net of the 900
because you lost the 10. You spent the
whole thing here. You invested it. Here
you spent it. But did you spend it or
did you invest it in asset you could
control? And so I don't know about you,
but I'd rather have the extra 50 and put
the 10 in. And then what do I do next
year? I'm gonna take this 50
and I'm gonna ask myself, is there
anything I could put this $50,000 into?
So, I could put in the S&P 500 and I
could go and add myself an extra uh
5,000 uh $55,000, whatever. Let's say I
get 10% that year. Okay, so I get 55,000
this year. Or I could put that 50K into
10 five 10K things or two 25K things and
all of a sudden take my earning power
from 100K to 250K.
Wow, what a deal. But I'm going to lose
the whole 50 again. And so the thing is
is that on my way up, I basically took
my savings and I spent it almost every
year on education because why on earth
would I want the future to take longer
to get to me? When you buy skills, it's
the closest approximation to buying
time. And so there's this big thing like
you can't buy time. False. You can buy
the future at a discount. and you buy
the future at a discount by buying the
skills required in order to get there
faster. And so if it could take you five
years if you did it on your own or it
could take you one year if you paid four
different people to help you out with
each step of the process, why would you
not want to pay all of the money you
have to get to there and then have four
years of gain with that new baseline.
You now are living four years, 5 years
into the future. It's like you skipping
from being 20 to 25 and you getting the
earning power at 25 plus, but now you're
just 21. And then when you're at that
point, you pull the next five years
forward. And when you're 22, it's like
living like you're 30, right? Like now
at that point though, you might spend
all your savings yet again. And this
process has been one that I have
consistently done for the entirety of my
career. And it just gets to a point
where you can't even spend the money.
And so my very controversial advice is
spend all your money on education for as
long as you possibly can until you can't
even spend the money because you're
making too much of it. And so how do you
become an expert? you do more
repetitions than anyone else in a narrow
field, which also means you fail more
times than anyone else in a narrow
field. And so, if you want to beat
someone, just try 10 times harder than
them. And you only really need to try
two or three times harder, but you
probably don't realize how much harder
they're trying than you are. So, try 10
times harder just to make sure you win.
People reject this idea that someone can
work 10 times or 100 times harder. But I
define work as output. And so for you to
say that someone can't produce 10 times
more than you is just factually false.
There's tons of people who produce 10
times more. There's tons of people who
produce a 100 times more than you. I'll
give you the easiest example in the
world. A lot of departments run on
weekly cadences. They say do this thing
by end of week. Often times you can ask
that person how many hours will this
really take you and then that person
will say something like I don't know
three or four hours. You say okay well
why don't you just get it done by noon.
And then at noon you say okay what's the
next thing going to take? and they'd
say, "Uh, probably another 3 or 4
hours." You say, "Cool, get it done by
the end of the day." Now, from those two
cycles, that would have normally taken 2
weeks or 14 days, but instead it got
done in one. And so, just right there,
you got something done. You got 14 times
more done than the competitor who's
doing things on a weekly basis. And so,
this is how you drag the future to the
present. Is that you're not focusing on
how hard you're working, you're focusing
how much you're getting done. You'd be
amazed at how much better you get after
you've done it a hundred times. If you
want to win, do it again. I want to be
clear, you don't just post a hundred
videos in a row and see what happens.
You post one, see what worked, and then
try and do more of that thing. And so,
the idea isn't just raw effort. It's raw
effort with an improvement loop. And so
I remember one of my favorite words that
I have to teach sales guys because it's
a very repetitive task to teach someone
how to sell is great, do it again, great
again. Great job again. And so it's that
repetition that breeds the nuance of
skill. And you want it to be so drilled
into you that you no longer have to
consciously think about how to do the
thing because you can then do it as a
natural skill so that you can move on to
putting your attention to the next
skill. So it's not just about learning
how to do it once. It's about learning
how to do it so many times that you
don't have to think about doing it at
all. Especially if you're starting out,
your goal should not be passive income.
Mainly because you don't have enough
money for the passive income to mean
anything. Instead, you should learn how
to make money while you're awake before
trying to learn how to make it while you
sleep. You crawl, then you walk, then
you run. Once you have more money than
you can possibly reinvest in education
and acquiring more skills, then you can
take the leftover and put that into your
passive income pool. And so, very, very
tactically, this is what I'll walk you
through. You should have an education
investment budget. And so, just like you
spend X dollars per month. So, let's say
you we pull all of your expenses down
and you're making an extra thousand a
month. Okay? Now, if you're not eating
out, you're not buying new clothes,
you're not going out with the boys,
you're not spending money in stupid
ways, that if that's what you're doing,
then you're going to have $1,000 left.
If you have that, then you can take that
money and every month you can put it
towards a bank account that you can
either choose to immediately spend or
save up for something that is more
expensive. And I can tell you that a lot
of what I learned when I when I bought
programs and seminars and conferences
and things like that wasn't even from
the content itself, but it was
connections that I was able to make at
those types of events that I was then
able to leverage the one skill I had,
which I was good at sales, and then
start giving that away to every person I
met so that I could collect those IUs
and then learn skills for free. And so
it's like I really just needed a ticket
to get in the room and then I could
trade with everybody else with the
skills I had to then get to learn
theirs. And so as wild as this sounds,
at the end of 2025, you could be dead
broke but rich in skills. And so let's
say at the end of next year, you
actually have no more money, but you now
have the ability to make more money. And
so just like my father had to start over
from nothing after losing everything, he
didn't lose everything. He still had the
most valuable thing he had, which is
that he was a surgeon. And so he knew a
skill and he could make it work here
like he'd make it work there. And that
is something that no divorce can take
from you, no government can confiscate.
And it's something that's with you till
the day you die. And so that's how you
get better. You keep going. You keep
improving the feedback loops. You invest
appropriately and you keep going allin
on you. We've eliminated everything
that's bad. We've started something
that's good. We've gotten even better at
being goodter. And now finally, we've
got to stick to it when it gets tough
because it will. Here's something that's
taken me way too long to learn. Staying
focused is like beating addiction. It's
not a one-time victory. You have to
fight it all day, every day, then wake
up and do it again tomorrow. Because the
thing that's going to distract you is
going to change every day. The thing
that's going to trigger your addiction
to distraction is going to keep morphing
and changing its form so that it can
steal or rob you of your future. And so,
you have to be adaptable in knowing that
you have to fight it every day. And so
it's not good enough to just say I was
focused for this week. You've got to
wake up on the eighth day and the ninth
day and do it again. And so you remember
that guy who uh got rich drop shipping
and day trading and uh buying crypto and
wholesaling all at the same time? Yeah.
Me neither. Focus. To win in business,
you need to be able to say no without
remorse and hear no without a loss of
enthusiasm. which means that you have to
keep feeling rejection, keep failing,
and keep going while being willing to
reject basically everyone else. And that
seems so counter because you're right
there and you're like, man, I don't want
to reject this person because I know
what it feels like to be rejected. You
need to be able to maintain this
discrepancy so that you can create the
space to do the work that needs doing.
So, there have been a couple of lessons
that I have learned over and over again
in my career. I've had to relearn. So,
it's a lot like a like a fine wine. It's
like it it gets better with age and
there's more nuance to the flavor. So, I
think focus is not a are you focused or
not. It's how focused are you? And you
can measure someone's focus by again the
quality and quantity of things that they
say no to. Which means that as you get
better, more opportunities will emerge,
which is interesting because people who
start out can't see opportunity
anywhere. And it's because they have so
few skills and so there's very few
opportunities for them. When you have a
lot of skills, there's so many
opportunities that are in front of you
that you feel like you're missing out.
But the real opportunity is actually in
solving the problems in front of you. I
was able to, in my opinion, become
another order of magnitude greater in
terms of entrepreneurship, which I would
just me measure by wealth. Once I was
able to learn to say no and accept that
I would not be able to pursue the many
things that I know I could crush because
once you realize how much actual work it
takes to make something good, you
realize how few things you're actually
going to be able to do in your entire
life. And so this is why picking becomes
so important. Right now the things that
you're going to have to say no to are
really the distractions and kind of in
some ways easy. Say no to fantasy
football, say no to drinking beers with
the boys, going out with the club,
whatever. But in a year from now, once
you have more skills, there will be more
opportunities. You're going to have
multiple $10,000 a month income
opportunities that you're going to have
to say no to to stick with the one that
you have. And then once that thing
becomes a $100,000 a month thing that
you're doing, you're going to have to
start saying no to multiple $100,000 a
month opportunities. And here's the
thing with opportunities that come up.
They only show you the upside and not
the downside. You have to know where the
skeletons are buried. You have to know
where the bodies are. If you don't know,
and I've gone through this this this
visual because I think about it every
single time I have to walk through not
doing something. You are here. You see
this new opportunity here. Then you
understand the downsides here. Then you
live the downsides. Then you experience
the upside. Then you achieve your goal.
And so this is the starting point. This
is called uninformed optimism. This is
now informed pessimism. This is the
value of despair and this is where most
people quit. But what they do is they
don't even quit because they don't want
to say they quit. What they do is they
start another one of these things and
they say, "Oh, this is now my uninformed
optimism." And then, "Oh, now I
understand this more." But the thing is
is that they never actually get through
to this upside. And so they just keep
jumping from thing to thing to thing
over and over again. And so the reason
it takes so long is because you're in a
rush. Big things don't happen on small
timelines because you have to start from
zero over and over again. And if you
actually stick with it, it's actually
the shortest way to get to where you
want to go. It just takes longer than
you think. Must be easy for you to say
is probably something that you might
think by watching this or listening to
this. And I like to tell this story
because in July of 2017 is when I
started my podcast and it was 90 days
after I lost everything, the last time.
And from that point until now, it's
taken that period of time to get to over
a million downloads a month. And for the
first 3 years, and I was making multiple
podcasts, so we're talking 3 400
episodes. For the first few years, I
never really cracked 3,000 downloads a
month. And so I could say, man, why is
this taking so long? But the real real
is that it took me that long to get
good. It also being extra real took me
that long to have proof on the outside
that what I was saying was true on the
inside. And right now, no one who
listens to my podcast cares that it took
me seven years to get here. They just
cared that it's good today. And so
people quit here when things get hard
because the thought of something being
hard forever is unbearable. They think
that this line is just going to keep
going this way forever. But it's not
because once you fully understand all
the bodies, where the skeletons are
hidden, then you can actually start
solving them one by one. The thing is is
that that distraction only is
distracting because you don't know what
sucks about it. You might think you know
what sucks about it, but you don't know
what sucks about it. And so the big
difference is you have something called
declarative versus procedural knowledge.
And so there's two types of learning.
And this is actually formal. This is uh
this is from academia. So you have
declarative knowledge which is knowing
about something.
So if you go memorize a fact or you you
you learn how private equity works,
right? This is knowing about. The other
type of knowledge is procedural,
which is knowing how to.
And so a lot of people mistake
declarative knowledge for procedural.
And so they mistakenly think that if
they watch 10 videos on doing a private
equity deal that it means they
understand how to do a private equity
deal. Or they watch 10 videos on cold
outbound and they think it means they
understand how to do cold outbound or 10
videos on sales and so forth. But you're
never really going to learn how to do it
until you do it. And so you're going to
learn more from your first hundred cold
calls, your hundred cold knock on doors
than you will from a hundred books or
videos that you watch. But I have good
news. Nothing hard lasts forever.
There's only three things that can
happen. You either quit, it gets easier,
or you get better. So no matter what, it
always ends. You only lose when you quit
before you see it all the way through.
And I think that's incredibly
encouraging. So no matter how hard
whatever it is that you're doing is,
which by the way just means that your
expectation doesn't match reality. But
no matter how hard it is, you either
quit, it gets easier because something
changes externally, or you get harder,
something changes internally, but no
matter what, it will end. Think about it
like you're you're mining for gold,
right? You're you're chiseling away
underground and you've got this pile of
gold. You don't know how far away it is,
but it's underground and you're digging
towards it. This difficulty of swinging
the the the pickaxe can end when one,
you walk out of the mine and say,
"There's you know what, marketing
doesn't work." Sure. The second is that
all of a sudden you hit a soft patch and
then you're like, "Oh my god, I'm
digging so much faster now. This is
great." And then you get to the gold or
you just start swinging the axe harder
because you get more muscled. You get
more efficient with your movements and
you just keep chiseling away. Even if it
goes from dirt to rock, you just keep
chiseling away at a slower pace, but you
eventually break through and get there.
But in all three of those scenarios,
hard doesn't last forever. And so I'll
give you a little rule of thumb that
I've seen on how do how do I do more of
what's working, right? How do I keep
going? When it's easy, do more. When
it's hard, do different. And so I told
this story years ago, and I'll tell you
guys again. So when Gym Launch just
barely started to work, all right, so
I'm like 3 months into Gym Launch
working, guess what? Guess what
brilliant Alex thought he should do? So
I went to this meetup of 10
entrepreneurs. All the entrepreneurs
were eight figure entrepreneurs, so 10
million plus per year. I was not making
that. I we were pacing probably three or
$400,000 a month at the time. It was
just me, Ila, and I think we had an
assistant over kitchen sink, right? So,
it was I was making the most money I'd
ever made in my life and probably to
this day because it was the most
material change in my life by
percentage. When you go from no money to
hundreds of thousands a month within 90
days, me looking at bankruptcy attorneys
6 months earlier to that, it's I can't I
can't explain how crazy reality shifted.
But I had this guy who came up to me
after I gave my little presentation of
like, hey, this is what's working. And
so, of course, what I want to do now is
start a supplement company. He came up
to me and he said, "If what you're
saying is true, if the economics of the
business that you've outlined really do
work as well as you say they do, when it
gets easy is when you go hard. It's when
you double down on what's working." And
he said that to me, and I remember he
said, "Because what's going to happen is
that if it really works this well,
someone bigger and better is going to
take all your stuff and immediately try
and do it with their distribution, their
audience, and their leverage. And so if
there's ever been a time to focus on the
thing that's in front of you, it's right
now. And I remember Leila and I felt
this huge weight of pressure that
started us at that point cuz literally I
think I was I was really content for
like 6 weeks and I was really thrilled.
We had just gotten married. We're 6
weeks into being, you know, married.
We're making really good money. Uh she's
23 or 24. I'm 26 or 27. So like we're
young. I was like, "Holy cow, this is
amazing." Our rent, for context, was
$1,200 a month. I was taking over 400,
right? Like, and so I've always lived
far below my means. At this point,
though, we went back home with the devil
inside of us in terms of the fear of us
losing everything that we had. And so,
we basically worked around the clock
like someone was trying to put us out of
business. And the thing is is that
people did eventually, but by the time
they did, we had gone so far ahead that
they were way behind us because we were
working against a hypothetical enemy who
was trying to destroy us, not the ones
that were actually mediocre and
distracted. When it's easy, do more.
Once it starts working, put the blinders
on and hit the gas. And I would
challenge you with this tactical setup
right now. If you've never worked for 30
days straight, I would encourage you to
try it. In China, there's something
called the 996, which is basically the
standard for Chinese tech work hours,
which is you work 9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m.
6 days a week. That's the bar. And so, I
like to state that because we think we
work so hard. That's just the average.
And so, I would encourage you, remember
hard times, hard men, right? Good times.
Well, we need to act as though it's hard
times because if you don't, you're
surely going to become soft. My
challenge for you is work 30 days
straight. Work 10, work 12 hours a day,
30 days straight. What you will realize
at the end of this is one, how much work
you can actually do. Two, that you're
not going to die. You're not made of
glass. And third, you'll know that you
have that gear if the time calls for it.
Now, I will be very real with you. I
work more now than I have ever worked in
my life. Save maybe when I opened my
very first gym. So, I work in absolute
hours more than I ever have. And I
produce significantly more than I did
then. And this year, I think I've taken
something like 10 or 11 days off in
2024. I would measure a day off as any
day where I worked probably fewer than
four hours. I put this as context and I
had a I had a security guard who was
here atacquisition.com
earlier this year and he was talking to
uh some of the younger guys on the team
and he said you should never let Alex
work more hours than you because he's
already ahead of you and so if you want
to catch up with him certainly don't let
him outwork you. Some of the hoodoo,
mental health, whatever people are going
to disagree with me also don't give a
And so the thing is is you can
just go and make those mental health
people happy or you can get what the
you came here to get. You can do
what you came to do. And I have found
that in my life, I've gotten
significantly more purpose and more
drive from a long day's hard work, from
earning my shower at the end of the day,
than anything that I've ever had from a
pleasure- seeeking perspective. As much
as it's great to go to the pool for a
day and hang out with some people or
maybe just watch movies, as great as
that may be, there's nothing that I get
more filming out of than knowing that at
the end of a day that I work 16 straight
hours that I have some product that I
pulled out of my brain and into the
world that this thing got life. Now,
looking back on the best days of my
life, it was those types of days. And so
when I realized that, I stopped trying
to satisfy what everyone else told me my
life was supposed to be like. They're
like, "You should take vacations." I
took my first vacation this year, and it
was supposed to be a two-day vacation,
and Leila and I left after one. Because
what happened was I got there at this
beautiful resort,5 or $10,000 a night,
very expensive. And I I say that just to
say that it was ritzy, right? It was
luxurious. I get there, I sit out on the
back of this beautiful patio for this
really expensive room and I look out on
this, you know, mountain view and I
think to myself, this is beautiful and I
don't care. I wish I felt something. And
all I wanted was to get back in the
game. And so I realized that even that
little mini vacation was something that
I had done because I thought it was an
expectation. It was unspoken or spoken
from someone else in my life. And so I
have this quote that I live by which is
if you don't know why you believe what
you believe, it's not your belief, it's
someone else's. At that time it's like I
had this belief that I should take a
vacation. But why? Now if I can't
explain it, which I really can't, then I
shouldn't do it. And now I want to be
very clear. This doesn't mean that
there's no time for rest. But I like to
think about the hypothetical extremes. I
like to think about the 996 that is just
the standard in China. And I like to
think about people in the middle ages in
the dark ages. They worked above their
shop and they didn't have like the 7-day
or 5day work week is something that was
invented in the last hundred years. This
is not pointing to your human capacity.
This is pointing to a societal
constraint. I think that a truly
liberated individual operates purely
from first principles of what do I want?
What does it take to get it? And then
what are the things that hold me back?
And those those things that hold you
back are gonna be physical constraints.
You can't operate without sleep. Not for
an extended period of time. So I'm not
saying don't sleep. Sleep as much as you
can. I'm not saying that you can work
physical labor all hours of the day
without rest. You need rest. And
sometimes you need mental rest, which is
different than physical rest. And that's
okay. So if you need, and I'm going to
put need in quotes here, if your way of
unplugging is watching Netflix, cool. If
your way of unplugging is gardening,
cool. If your way of unplugging is
working out, cool. do what works for
you. But fundamentally, the goal is to
increase total net output over the
longest period of time. And so, it's not
about, okay, I'm going to work 24 hours
straight. Well, you're actually going to
take from tomorrow. So, your net output
over two days is going to be much worse.
And so, it's really balancing that. And
I learned that much later in life. I was
able to get significantly more out of
myself working seven days a week and
working 10 hours, 12 hours on those days
rather than working call it 18 every
day. That was for me a little bit too
much. Now I have had seasons where I
call it three shifts. So basically I
work 6:00 to noon, noon to 6, and then I
work 6 to basically sleep time when I
get back home. I only usually have to go
into that gear probably once a year for
maybe six weeks to eight weeks is when I
have to go into the third shift. But
most of the times I can pretty much
sustain 12 hours of work a day kind of
indefinitely. I bring this up to kind of
set the bar for at least where I'm at.
So maybe you have some sort of
benchmark, but if you're wanting to get
ahead, I can promise you working less is
probably not the way to do it.
especially when you don't have as many
skills because the fewer skills that you
have, the more labor or volume you have
to compensate with in order to make up
for the ineffectiveness per unit of time
you work. And so in the beginning is
when you actually have to work the most,
but in the end is when you want to work
the most because of how much more you're
getting for it. So my team wanted me to
make this point because they've
obviously seen me work and they're like,
I don't think this is coming through in
this video, which is that I have an
obsession with speed. This seems kind of
weird in juxtaposition with patience,
but this is the very classic micro
speed, macro patience, you know,
whatever whatever whatever ism you
prefer. The idea is though that you want
to pull reality forward. And so I always
like to break things down, whether it's
me or my team, into how many hours and
minutes something's going to take. And
then I like to stack those things back
and forth. And rather than using
arbitrary deadlines of, okay, let's get
this done by next week, you use actual
deadlines based on how long it should
take. And then when you find out how
long something takes, you then ask the
next question, which is, how can I make
this take less time? How can I automate
this thing? How can I automate portions
of this work? How can I how can I give
away chunks of this? How can I deem some
of this unnecessary? And so that
continuous cutting and pulling forward
of tasks is how you can move so much
faster through life and towards your
goals. And so I have this weird mental
belief that there's like this this big
path in front of me that I have all
these skills that I have to achieve to
hit these milestones that is laid out on
this time span. And so I reject the
timeline, but I accept the skills. And
so the idea is like, okay, it's like I'm
a Pac-Man of like eating those little
dots and each of those dots is a skill.
It's like I want to pull it towards me
as fast as I can so I can so I can
ingest the skills and basically power up
myself faster because I know that these
skills are requisites. I can't move on
to calculus without knowing arithmetic.
I can't move on to calculus without
knowing algebra. There's no way around
it. But I can choose to learn algebra
faster. And so then it's like, okay,
what is required to learn algebra? Oh,
and if I do more problems faster than
the standard person, then I'll get there
faster. And so if the class says, "Okay,
I need you to do these 10 problem sets
and they're due next week." Well, then
how long does it take for me to do those
problems, maybe 30 minutes, then why
can't I do my second lesson 30 minutes
later and then do another 10 problems
and do my third lesson 30 minutes after
that and do another 10 problems? Well,
if that's the case, then I can do an
entire year's worth of work in a week.
And this is how in my opinion pulling
forward is one of those things that I've
seen so many of the most successful
entrepreneurs do is they simply question
timelines
aggressively and ruthlessly eliminate
any waste or gap between the actions
required to win and everything else.
Honestly, I think the things that I'm
working on right now for my skills are
I'm learning how to
reinforce
cultural norms across a company that
continues to scale which I define as the
rules that govern reinforcement in an
organization. That is the culture and
those are both spoken and unspoken
rules. And when I say rules, I mean when
someone does this, they get a pat on the
butt. when someone does this, they get
uh chastised or they get a ding, right?
And the thing is is that people like to
say they have a good culture here. But
the culture is is is hundred a thousand
unspoken rules and that's why it takes
people time to learn and figure out what
the culture is when they go somewhere
new. You can give someone a list of a
hundred rules and if you were very
granular, you could figure it out. The
problem is that the culture changes
based on the people who change the
reinforcers. And so that means that the
culture in a team could be different
than the culture in the company because
the person who's closest to them uh
manages it differently. And so that
changes the behavior. And so that's why
a sales team can have a different
culture than a marketing team, a
different culture than a finance team,
different culture than an HR team. And
so I'd say right now a big focus of me
of mine is trying to standardize the
rules that govern reinforcement across
an organization that scales and making
sure that everyone is aligned with that
style of work. The second thing that I'm
working on right now is basically the
highest level of recruiting. And
recruiting and talent is actually kind
of like focus where it's one of those
skills that I don't think you ever
master. You just keep learning how many
more levels there are to it. It's like
right when you finish it, you realize
that you're at a sub peak and there's
actually another peak beyond it. The
missed lifts and then you see the next
steps. And so like focus, I thought,
"Oh, I was focused at $100,000 a month
because I could turn these opportunities
down." And then you got some even sexier
opportunities. You got to learn how to
say no to those. So the same thing
happens with talent is that you're
willing to tolerate a certain amount of
mediocrity at one level that is no
longer tolerable at a level above that.
And the types of people that you bring
in, you have a higher standard, a higher
bar for those people and attracting them
in the process associated with getting
them to buy into your culture, your
vision, and getting them to take their
skills and apply them to your
opportunity is a skill set that I am
working on now because fundamentally I
have a belief which is the best talent
is always yet to come. And that's
predicated on the idea that if I get
better, my opportunity will get better
and that will attract more people and
better people. And I bring this up
because I basically want to translate
one thing, which is that the
reinvestment in learning skills never
ends. And so Charlie Mer said this, you
just have to be a lifelong student. You
have to be willing and want to learn. So
I actually had um an example of this. So
recently there was somebody on uh teams.
I did a bunch of one-on- ones uh over
the last week because I was looking at
one of the departments and uh one of the
one of the guys said, "Hey, I have this
particular skill. I was hoping that we
could eventually have a a role that only
does this thing." And I said, "You know,
it's interesting that you that you ask
or you make that request because if I
were you, I would not think that way at
all. I would think how could I learn 10
more skills." Rather than how can the
organization meet my demands, it should
be how can I let my skills meet the
demands of the existing business. It's
asking reality to meet you where you're
at rather than meeting reality where it
is. And I think that too many people do
this. Why can't the world insert be more
convenient for me? Well, the world is
uncaring and doesn't care about you at
all. And underline underpinning that
statement is the entitlement is the
expectation that it somehow should. And
I think that is a poverty lens. And so
the wealthy accept the world for what it
is and then choose to maximize and
adapt. Everyone else tries to stomp
their feet and throw tantrums and say
how it's not fair. And they're right.
And so what? There's a Haitian proverb
that has nothing to do with cats and
dogs that I think is relevant right now,
which is behind mountains are more
mountains. Goals aren't finish lines,
they're mile markers. And I think that's
a great mental frame, which is that you
think that your goal is to get to
$10,000 a month or $100,000 a month or a
million a month or 10 million a month,
whatever your goal is. And I can promise
you, having hit those, you just move it
again. You just the mist lifts when you
get there and you realize there's
another mountain top. But where people
lose their way is when they start
listening to people at the bottom of the
mountain who see them at the subhead and
say, "You weren't happy last time when
you got to the last peak. Why are you
going to be happy the next time?" But
that's under their assumption in their
poverty lens that you did it to get to
the mountaintop. You did it for the
climb and they'll never understand that
and don't expect them to. I remember I
was trying to understand this person who
had made this really irrational decision
and I kept thinking like how how does
this decision make sense and I was I was
talking to my father actually and he
said you're trying to apply logic to
someone who's illogical and that itself
is illogical and I remember thinking
about that is that like there are these
people in our lives that say these
things that you're like I don't
understand why they'd say that and then
you try and make sense of it but the
effort of trying to make sense of
somebody who doesn't make sense is
nonsensical. And so if it doesn't make
sense to you, ignore it because they're
going to disappear anyways. One of the
things that has been true in my life is
that the lazy don't know how to start,
the losers don't know how to finish, and
the legends don't know how to stop. And
if I look at that, the lazy losers and
legends, I know which one I would rather
be. And I also say that as somebody who
doesn't believe in legacy or anything
after we die. So, this is tactical. Find
what works. Do more of what works. Find
the thing that's preventing you from
doing more of what works. Solve that
thing and get back to doing more of what
works. Then repeat. And so, the reality
is that in health, marriage, business,
or any game worth playing. You don't win
by winning. You win by staying alive
long enough that you outlast everyone
else. So, I will give you the advice
that I gave a sub group in school that
we picked a hundred people who had
applied out of 500 plus to basically do
a 90-day sprint to help them start a
school community. So, we wanted to do a
more in-depth kind of training, things
like that for the special group so that
we could see if this new implementation
yielded better results. And so, the guy
who we had running the group asked me,
he said, "Can you give any kind of like
words of wisdom to these guys before we
kick it off?" And so, this is what I
told them. Number one, follow
instructions. Number two, when you reach
something that you don't understand how
to do, Google first. Number three, when
you figure it out, post it. Others also
may have struggled. Four, actually
follow the rule of 100 daily, which is
that you reach out to a 100 people, you
make a post that you spend 100 minutes
on, spend $100 plus on ads, and you
spend at least 100 minutes a day making
and improving ads and researching ads.
As long as you do those things
consistently and you get better, you
will see results. And the amount of you
that I see who tagged me in like day
four, day 20, day 30, the guys who are
at day 60 of rule of 100 are like, I
have more business than I can possibly
handle. The problem is no one sticks
with anything. And this is why I want
you to stick with it. Rule number five,
you will be excited for a week. Then
excitement will end. And that is where
the work begins. Six, your work works on
you more than you work on it. You are
the product that's getting built more
than anything that you're actually
putting into your business. Remember
that. Seven, everything is unscalable in
the beginning. That's the point. It's
how you learn every piece of it. And
once you learn every piece of it, people
will call you an expert. Eight, the pain
of repetition is what forces you to seek
improvement. When you figure out ways to
get more for what you do, you've gained
skill. People want to avoid the pain.
One of my favorite bodybuilding coaches,
Milo SVev, talks about this in the
context of how to grow a muscle. He
says, "Find the pain." And then he'll
just shout, he be like, "Suffer.
Suffer." He's like, "Stay there. Find
the pain." Because the thing is is that
that pain is what forces you to change.
And so if you encounter the pain and
then say, "Oh, it's not working." That's
the pain that you need to lean into.
Because when it's not working is what
will force you to do an improvement. And
that's how you get good at making better
content, get good at making better ads,
get good at having more effective
reachouts on different channels,
whatever. It's that pain that forces you
to improve. Nine, if you complain, you
are dead to me. And I said this because
I believe it. Like there is nothing
weaker and more helpless and that has
lower agency than someone who simply
complains about what has occurred. It's
something that happened in the past or
is in front of them in the present. And
regardless, complaining literally does
nothing. It's a net zero. It's a net
loss. You both lose the energy that you
could have spent improving. And you also
lose respect from every single person
that you complain to. And they will
associate the complaints with you. They
won't remember what you complain about,
only that you complain. 10. Literally
thousands of people have already
succeeded. You are not special. Repeat
the same activities and you will be able
to repeat the same outcomes. Before you
make a conclusion that something doesn't
work, I want you to state the objective
truth of what you're claiming. You're
like, Facebook ads don't work. Sure. So
the 400 billion a year in advertising
that gets spent on Facebook just somehow
doesn't work. People aren't doing it
because it's not working. Cold outbound
doesn't work. Yeah. So, the gazillion
companies that do 10,000 emails, 10,000
calls a day, they just it just it
doesn't work. What you have to reframe
it as is, I don't know how to make it
work. I am not good enough to know how
to make it work because you're not
making as much money as you want because
you're not as good as you think you are.
11. Write down every reason that you're
going to stick with it. Put it in front
of you and revisit it when you need a
reminder of why to stick with it. 12.
Business is shockingly simple but
surprisingly hard. The hard comes in the
form of consistency. The moment you
don't want to do it or just skip today
is the day you realize what hard
actually feels like. Learn to endure,
overcome. 13. Just win. Because at the
end of the day, all of this hardship
will be forgotten. It will fade into
your memory. And so know that as you're
going through it, you're actually just
going to disproportionately in your
memory remember the good stuff and not
the bad stuff. I only have a few
glimpses in my memory of the time when I
was sleeping on the floor and I and I,
you know, had my gym and I was getting
started and I remember being so tired
that like a good night's sleep couldn't
fix it. I remember that. But it's almost
like I remember the words that I told
myself more than I even remember the
experiences because it was so long ago.
Things will get better and you will
remember the betterness more than you
remember the suffering because the
betterness will carry over in today
which will always be fresher for you
than how long ago the suffering may have
been. If you want to just win, I made an
entire presentation on winning. It's
actually my favorite piece of content
that I've made in YouTube format. I'd
recommend watching